[Background music]
[An ephemeral image of clouds and a horse and buggy approaching from the left come into view.]
[Dr. Lowell:] Howdy, folks, remember me? John Lowell, family doctor.
Time was when I took pretty good care of the people hereabouts.
...was with them when they were born and when they died, tried to make the years in between
just as healthy and happy as I could. But
I don't get around here very much nowadays.
[Ghostly figure of Dr. Lowell drives along
in horse-drawn carriage and stops in front of a home,
then gets out and approaches the front door.]
I guess maybe you're wondering what I'm doing
here now. Well, it's like this, I've been
wanting to drop in on Plainville again, visit
some of the folks, see how the old world's
getting along.
[Music]
Let's look in on the Jones family, see how
they're doing.
[A family sits around the table preparing to have breakfast.]
You know them, don't you? They're your neighbors,
could be yourselves.
This is Henry Jones. Henry's a skilled mechanic down at the McGregor
Tool and Die Works.
Looks like he's reading something that bothers him.
Here's Sally and her baby. Sally was married to Henry's oldest son, David.
He was with MacArthur in the Pacific, one of the expendables. He won't be coming back.
And here's my old friend Deborah Jones, Henry's
mother. I knew Debbie when she was in pigtails.
Still got that saucy gleam in her eye though,
and that stubborn chin, forever talking about
the good old days. Just won't give in to admitting how much better things are today.
[Radio announcer:] Hello, hello, hello, this
is Jolly Charlie again with a brand new tune,
Speak of Moonlight.
[Henry:] Turn that thing off.
[Granny:] Now Henry Jones, we let you read your newspaper in peace, you let us enjoy our radio.
[Henry:] All right, all right, mother, anything
to keep the peace. But it hurts.
[Granny:] That was my favorite announcer and
he always plays the records I like.
[Sally:] [Yes, Granny.]
[Grace:] Hi everybody.
[Henry:] Hello honey.
[Sally:] Where are you working today, Grace?
[Grace:] At the high school, Sally. Dr. Johnson's
finishing up his student's physical examination.
Bill's going to help too.
[Granny:] That accounts for your high spirit.
[Grace:] What'd you say, Granny?
[Granny:] Oh, shut that thing off. Nobody
can hear me.
[Granny:] I said you're as merry as a cricket
because Bill McGregor's going to be with you today.
[Mother:] Now Granny, you know Bill has nothing to do with it. Gracie is there because she loves her work.
[Granny:] Oh yes, I suppose it's just one
of those things, Gracie taking a job in a
hospital where Bill's an intern.
[Grace:] You know very well I like my job,
Granny. It's swell being a part of such wonderful work.
And those health records I've been keeping
up with school kids' exams...that's health
in the bank, Granny. They pay real dividends.
[Granny:] Well, I do declare. What are the
examinations for?
Is there some kind of an epidemic in town?
[Laughter]
[Grace:] Goodness no, we don't wait for epidemics,
Granny, we try to prevent them.
[Granny:] Well, in my day we didn't go to
a doctor until we were really sick.
[Grace:] That's just the point; you can't
tell whether or not you're really sick.
That's up to the doctor.
[Henry:] That girl has a lot of sense, mother. You shouldn't belittle her interest in her work.
[Mother:] Now where is that boy? Late again. Peter, Peter.
[Peter:] Okay, okay, I'll make it.
[Sally:] We have a date this afternoon, haven't
we, Dickey boy? We're going to go to the clinic
and see that everything's all right, every
little finger and toe and eye and ear
and that new tooth.
[Granny:] I think it's all stuff and nonsense,
taking the baby to the clinic every month.
If he were my baby I'd never take him there
at all, being pawed over and bounced around
by a lot of doctors and nurses and all sorts
of people.
[Mother:] Why don't you go down to the clinic
and see for yourself what it's like, Granny?
[Granny:] Who me? Deborah Jones go to a clinic?
[Peter:] Watch it, Granny, you'll get high
blood pressure.
[Granny:] High blood pressure, fiddlesticks.
[Henry:] I think Sally's smart to watch out
for the baby's health like she does.
It'd be a good thing if we all did it. I was just reading here, 160,000 people die of cancer
every year.
Some of these deaths are the result of people going to quacks for treatment,
some because they don't go to an accredited doctor until
too late.
But, cancer can be cured if it's treated in
time and by the approved methods of
surgery, x-ray, and radium.
And it says that tuberculosis and a lot of
other diseases can be cured if they're discovered
early enough. People certainly ought to go
to the doctor.
[Sally:] Instead of doctoring themselves.
[Granny:] We didn't go looking for trouble
in my day.
[Henry:] No mother, you didn't. And that's
why so many died before their time.
[Granny:] I still say when it comes time for
a person to die, they die.
There's just nothing anybody can do about it.
[Henry:] Oh well.
[Dr. Lowell:] I wouldn't say that, Deborah.
If I'd known what doctors know now, I might
have been able to save your baby, the one
that died of diphtheria.
Nowadays, diphtheria toxoid is saving thousands
of lives every year.
Deborah Jones, stop gulping those pills and listen to me.
Sally believes in prevention and deep down
in your heart you know she's right, only you're
too darn stubborn to admit it.
[Granny:] I'm not stubborn.
[Henry:] Well nobody said you were, mother.
[Mother:] What's the matter, Granny?
[Granny:] Why, nothing's the matter. What
should be the matter? Mind your baby, Sally.
[Henry:] Well, I've got to be going.
[Peter:] Goodbye Pop.
[Granny:] Goodbye son.
[Mother:] Goodbye Henry.
[Henry:] Goodbye. Goodbye mother.
[Mother:] Goodbye dear.
[Granny:] If you go to food like that, young
man, you'll need one of my digestion pills.
[Peter:] No I won't, Granny, with a breakfast
like this under my belt, nothing will hurt me.
[Granny:] Don't be impudent, Peter, and don't
talk with your mouth full.
[Grace:] Don't forget to show up for your
physical at school this morning
and get your chest x-ray report.
[Peter:] Okay, okay. Hey sis, did you see
that x-ray report? Was it all right?
[Mother:] Why Peter, I'm so glad to see you
take an interest in your health.
[Peter:] I don't care anything about my health.
I just want to be okay for football.
[Grace:] Being okay for football isn't being
healthy, oh certainly not.
[Phone ringing.] Oh, that's Bill. I'll get it.
Hello? Yes darling, I'm just leaving now.
Yes, I'll be right over.
[Bill:] Mother and I are a bit worried about
dad. I want to stop off at the plant and see how he's feeling.
[Grace:] Oh, all right dear, bye bye.
Bill's worried about his father. He's going
to get the plant doctor
to sell him the idea of a checkup.
[Mother:] I hope it's nothing serious.
[Grace:] I hope not. I'll ask Bill about it
when I see him. I'll have to run along.
[Peter:] Me too. Goodbye mom. Goodbye gang.
[Mother:] Goodbye, son.
[Grace:] Goodbye, Peter.
[Granny:] Goodbye dear.
[Grace:] Oh Sally, I left the health pamphlet
that you wanted over there.
[Sally:] Oh swell. Have a good day, Grace.
[Grace:] Thanks. Bye everybody.
[Mother:] Well I'll clear away.
[Sally:] Oh, I'll help.
[Mother and Sally begin clearing the table. Granny waits until they leave the room, then gets up, locates a document on the sideboard, and slips it into her pocket.]
[Sally:] You wouldn't want to come to the
clinic with Dickey and me today, would you?
[Granny:] Now Sally, don't start that again.
By the way, Sally, has your baby had its
diphtheria shot or whatever you call it?
[Sally:] Why, of course he has. What made you ask that?
[Granny:] I was just remembering. Well, never
mind...
[Sally:] Maybe if you'd read about what's
going on, that pamphlet that Grace left me.
Well, what's become of it?
[Granny:] Guess I'll go over to see Mrs. Allen.
[Sally:] That's funny, I'm sure she left it
here. I wonder who picked it up?
[Granny:] Oh, I suppose anybody is liable
to pick up things that are lying around.
I guess that's why folks leave them lying about, just to tempt people. Stubborn, who's stubborn?
High blood pressure, ha [inaudible].
[Sally:] Now what can be the matter with Granny?
[Dr. Lowell:] I'll tell you. Tthe matter with
Granny is that the old hard shell seems to
be softening up a bit. She's always been so sure of herself,
but it isn't her pills that keep her going.
It's the walk she takes, the foods she eats,
the catnap she has after lunch.
Too bad I can't give Granny A for attitude.
Now for a look at the younger generation.
Here's a mighty fine school health service.
These Plainville doctors are certainly doing
a grand job.
Periodic checkups like these give them a chance
to prevent illness
instead of half a chance to cure it.
Bright youngster this, but lately she's been
falling behind in her work.
Now the mystery is solved. Jane needs glasses.
Tommy once had rheumatic fever, growing pains
some folks call it, but the wise ones, like
Tommy's mother, sent him to the doctor and that's why Tommy's all right now.
Bill McGregor is responsible for a mighty
important part of the checkup.
Teeth certainly get a lot of care these days
and that's as it should be.
And our young friend, Peter Jones, wonder
if he'll make out all right?
[Doctor:] Everything's fine, Pete.
[Peter:] And the chest x-ray too?
[Doctor:] I'm glad to see you weren't worried
about it. Some of the other boys who had a
positive tuberculin test got all excited.
[Peter:] Why should I get excited? You told
me that didn't mean I had TB, just that I
needed a chest x-ray to make sure.
[Doctor:] Good boy, Pete. I wish everyone
would listen as carefully and get the facts right.
[Peter:] So I can go out for the team?
[Doctor:] You certainly can.
[Dr. Lowell:] Too bad Grandpa Jones didn't
live to see Peter make the team.
But Grandpa died of TB, didn't even know he had it until it was too late.
[Music, then background noise in a plant.]
[Bill:] Annette O'Brian, Joe Benton and Sam Carsey as committee members. As chairman
of our new health and safety committee you
have elected Henry Jones.
All of you men get behind your committee and let's put this health program over with a bang.
[Dr. Stewart:] How are you, Jones?
[Henry:] How are you, doctor?
[Dr. Stewart:] It's a real job and I know
you can handle it. Let's go in and see the big boss.
We have a date to talk things over
and I'd like you to come along and give us your ideas.
[Henry:] Fine. Just a minute. Grant, take
over, will you?
You know I think we've got something, doctor.
[Dr. Stewart:] Glad you feel that way.
[Henry:] Doctor, looks like my lunchbox.
[Dr. Stewart:] That's vitamin glamour my boy. [Laughter]
Go right in, Jones.
[Henry:] Thank you, doctor.
[Dr. Stewart:] Our new health committee chairman,
Mr. McGregor.
[McGregor:] Yes, I just heard. Congratulations,
Jones.
[Henry:] Thank you, Mr. McGregor. I'll do
the best I can.
[McGregor:] Won't you sit down, gentlemen?
[Dr. Stewart:] The health department has notified
me they can move in their equipment for a
chest x-ray next week. How about it Mr. McGregor?
[McGregor:] Fine, I think a chest x-ray is
a safety device that every man needs.
Our plant has a record for working conditions, less absenteeism from illness and injury than most.
[Henry:] In these mass x-rays, Dr. Stewart,
does everybody get to know the other fellow's business?
The boys wouldn't like that.
[Dr. Stewart:] No, the reports are confidential, like all the medical examinations in this plant.
[McGregor:] Another thing, the x-rays are
free to the men and made on company time too.
[Henry:] Well, in that case I'm sure the boys will be 100 percent for it. I wonder if you could
give us some sort of health pamphlets and
things like that that we could hand around,
[McGregor:] How about it?
[Dr. Stewart:] Yes, sure. We can get plenty
of good information free, like those leaflets
from the tuberculosis association. You know
they're working very closely every step of
the way with the health department. We can get movies too, and transcriptions for the loudspeaker.
[McGregor:] Any other ideas?
[Dr. Stewart:] I'd like an occasional half
hour on the company's time for a health talk to the men.
[McGregor:] Well, I feel sure the board will
grant that request. I'll take it up with them.
Another thing, I...
[McGregor faints onto his desk. Dramatic
music plays.]
[Dr. Stewart:] Better call an ambulance, Jones.
[Henry:] Hello operator, call an ambulance
quickly, yes.
[Bill:] Don't worry, Dad, you're going to
be all right.
[McGregor:] They tell me I have coronary heart trouble. What does that mean?
[Dr. Stewart:] Coronary heart trouble?
Well, without getting too technical it simply means that your coronary arteries have hardened up a bit.
When that happens the heart muscle gets less blood, not enough food and oxygen.
[McGregor:] I thought that happened to old
men. I'm only 48.
[Dr. Stewart:] You're in the prime of life.
But this kind of heart trouble hits hardest
at men around your age.
[McGregor:] Am I all washed up, doctor?
[Dr. Stewart:] No, of course not. But you're
going to have to stay right where you are
for a while and obey orders. It's not going
to be quick and it's not going to be easy
to get you back on your feet again. You've
got to get your mind off the plant and stop worrying.
[Bill:] Cheer up, young fellow. You've got
all the specialists in the hospital and your
own son to look after you.
[Dr. Stewart:] Remember now, take it easy.
[Dr. Lowell:] Yes, Bill, your dad's a pretty
sick man, but we know he's not fighting alone
and he knows it, too. And you've got this
up-to-date hospital with its modern blood bank,
its lifesaving medicine, new as today's
arrivals,
physical therapy at its latest and best.
All important laboratory service.....
X-ray that looks inside the body and takes
the guesswork out of diagnosis,
skilled hands and brains, disciplined teamwork, ready for any emergency.
[Grace:] How's your father, Bill?
[Bill:] It's going to be a long hard pull,
Gracie.
[Grace:] I'm sure he'll be all right. He's
always been so healthy. I don't know much
about medicine, Bill, and please don't think
I'm just being a little dumb, Bill.
[Bill:] You're being just swell, Gracie. It
means a lot having you here with me now.
[Grace:] You know I love you, Bill.
I'm glad I can be here close to you and your father when you need me.
[Bill:] So am I, honey.
[Grace:] Why that's Granny going into the
clinic with Sally and the baby.
[Sally:] This is Mrs. Deborah Jones, nurse,
Dickey's great-grandmother. This is her very
first visit to the clinic and I persuaded
her to come. It was a tough fight but we made it.
[Nurse:] Dr. Johnson is ready to see you now, Mrs. Jones, you may go in.
[Sally:] Granny, you mean you actually made
an appointment here before we even talked
about coming?
[Granny:] You don't think a slip of a girl
like you could persuade me to do something
I hadn't a mind to do? I persuaded myself.
Or maybe it was that voice that's been whispering to me.
[Sally:] What voice?
[Granny:] You wouldn't know. It was someone
long before your time.
[Sally:] What are you going to have done?
What's the matter, Granny?
[Granny:] You're always asking what's the
matter? Nothing's the matter. I'm going to
have a general checkup. I guess I can have
one if everybody else in the town is having one.
I'm not as stubborn as you think.
[Sally:] But I never said you were, Granny.
[Dr. Lowell:] Yes, it's a wonderful thing,
this clinic. No wonder the people of Plainville
are using it more and more, including Granny.
But Sally knew about it all along.
Dickey is the healthy proof of that.
[Sally, reading questionnaire:] Do you take your baby regularly to the physician or the well-baby clinic?
Yes.
Has every member of your household had a recent
physical examination including a chest x-ray?
Yes. Even Granny.
Dickey is one baby well-protected against
disease.
He's going to be healthy, wealthy, and wise.
[Peter:] How're you doing, Granny?
[Granny:] They tell me I'm doing all right,
Peter. But I always knew that.
You won't catch me winding up with too little, too late. It can't happen to me.
I'm doing all right.
[Dr. Lowell:] That you are, Deborah. When
an old diehard like you sees the light,
it proves nobody's ever too old to learn.
You know, doctors have found out a lot of
new things since my day, yes siree.
Nowadays they can prevent illness. Of course, they can't do it alone.
They must have your help. That's why the ones who give me hope are the young folks:
Grace and Bill, Sally and young Peter. They're learning that health is a personal responsibility
and they're doing something about it.
And healthy kids like that young Dickey, they
guarantee this old world a new lease on life.
Well, I guess I better be getting along now.
Giddy up, Jim, go on boy.